so you're just gonna like pay someone to
come over and hang out with your cat
yeah they can't take care of themselves
why don't you just let them go and hang
out with the neighborhood cats the form
like a lion king they're gentle cats
Kahlan they can't survive on the outside
isn't that right mr. Harris how does
face get all smushed like that
that's the breed they're supposed to
look like that oh so you didn't like
raise them in a jar like one of those
Japanese cubed watermelons no Kaylin
cats cannot grow in jars I did not do
that
fight a cat I'd want him to just be a
furry cube with legs oh that's one of
the people that answered my ad oh whoa
whoa whoa what are you doing I'm gonna
be gone for a week it's already getting
sour please you go do the interview let
me worry about the food all right you're
not gonna drink it are you no I see you
have degrees in cat and dog behavior
it's important to know the enemy true
there's a war brewing with the dog
community what is your experience with
problem cats mr. Harris has two strikes
with the Humane Society mr. Harris come
well it doesn't usually respond to
English impressive Albert excuse me for
just a second hi I'm Jenny
oh hi I'm here for the cat sitter
interview oh right
Jenny hi I'm Elliot nice to meet you
meet you uh you're you're here early
though oh uh I can come back later
no no you should say okay just give me a
second sure he was okay this okay I'm
sorry
okay uh hey Albert no this is Kailen
he's Brittany purses cat Godfather hey
don't call me that
yeah so why don't you guys I hang out
and talk about cats for awhile you love
cats right okay
right hey you know that show cat dog you
ever seen one of those I have so you're
you're an actress
living in LA yeah it's been okay I do a
lot of side gigs to keep the lights on
oh yeah I been like dealing drugs and oh
yeah yeah heroin meth coke oh my god
really no no I'm totally kidding oh
right cool cool super cool so do you do
you like cats mm-hmm yeah I have a cat
banjo he's a little shy but super sweet
oh that's great
have you ever cats at know Albert's the
clear choice but something about Jenny
you can just say you like her is it
unethical to hire someone because you
want to date them
no I mean I went out with my probation
officer you're a terrible person
I'm a great person you have a probation
officer Elliot I'd expect you of all
people not to buy into America's prison
industrial complex
I just want to know my cats are gonna be
okay I need to hire the best person I
mean you really do whatever you want I
kind of don't care anymore
yeah you're right I'm gonna move on to
phase two sure okay it's time for
Brittany purses pill how do you give it
to her insert the capsule into an edible
pill pocket place it in her mouth and
gently massage it down her throat just
hide it in some delicious human food I
love human human food often contains
spices which are poisonous to cats
that is true next question mr. Harris is
sitting in the loaf position on the
couch and will not move what do you do
well first take a photo because that's
too cute
loping can be a sign of stress I would
have to call the vet all right next
question
Brittany pers has mild hemorrhoids what
happens when she can't move due to the
burning sensation with me at all times
those clinical strength indeed
welcome to the freeform section of the
interview process so how would you
describe their fantasy island it'd be a
little island with just this house in it
that's it you'd be in it all the time
you never go to work because you're
their whole universe
thank you for coming Albert but I'll see
ya good luck with your hemorrhoid
ointment and all that okay bye thank you
so much thank you I'll see you next
Friday yes please I can't wait yeah bye
bye did you ask around hmm no not yet
and you're not going to probably not I'm
terrified cat threw up on your bed but
my cats can't throw up did you drink all
their milk
you
you